Guten Gönn, mein Name ist...
Ich bin heute der Dierend Sabende und für Sie ist es 3.
Und bevor wir uns über Ihre Aktuelle Bechwerden unterhalten,
würde ich gerne Ihnen über Ihre Personneldaten eine gefragt stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, ich heiße Monika Lindemann.
Monika Lindemann.
Monika Mitka, oder Sie?
Ja, Monika Mitka.
Könnt ihr die Bechwerden über die Bechwerden bechreiben?
Ja, Lindemann.
Lindemann.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Wie alt sind Sie?
42.
14. Juni 1983.
Juni, oder?
Juni.
1983.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
69 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m.
Okay, Frau Lindemann.
Ja.
Sprehe ich Ihren Nachnamen richtig.
Ich sprae Ihre Nachnamen richtig.
Ja.
Okay.
Was für Sie zu uns?
Welche Bechwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden langsam stärker.
Zwei Tage stärker geworden.
Ja.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Bauchschmerzen genau bechreiben?
Wie der Schmerz ist oder wo der Schmerz ist?
Wie?
Ja, der Schmerz ist so ein Dauerschmerz.
Etwas bohrend, wie bohrender Schmerz.
Etwas bohrender Schmerz.
Und manchmal ist er auch etwas wellenförmig.
So, dass er geht und kommt.
Aber er ist immer da.
Kommend und gehen da?
Ja.
Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Könnten Sie bitte
mir sagen
wo die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, sie sind so links,
mehr links im Bauch.
Links vom Bauchnabel
auf der linken Seite.
Und
strahlen die Schmerzen
irgendwo hinaus?
Nein.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, links seitig,
aber kommt vom Nabel.
Links vom Nabel.
Also auf der linken Bauchseite.
Bauchnabel.
In Höhe des Bauchnabels, danach links, mehr.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und
ja, Sie haben dauerhaft
bohrend und wellenförmig
und
Schmerzen
auf linken Seite.
Und linken Seite.
Ja.
Und gibt es etwas,
was die Schmerzen
verstärken
oder verlindern?
Also wenn ich auf den Bauch drücke
mit den Händen, wenn ich draufdrücke,
dann wird das schlimmer.
Am besten ist, wenn ich mich ruhig
hinliege auf den Rücken
und die Knie etwas anziehe
zum Körper, das ist besser.
Ja.
Sind diese Schmerzen
Bewegung abhängig?
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, ich möchte.
Wenn Sie laufen oder gehen.
Ja, ja, laufen und gehen,
das mache ich nicht gerne.
Das verstärkt den Schmerz.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich habe gemessen.
38,5.
Und
von wo haben Sie gemessen?
Von der Mund.
Haben Sie heute gemessen?
Ja, vor einer Stunde.
Und haben Sie
Schmerzhafte, Wasserlassen?
Oder
Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung?
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass
Ihre
in Ihrem Irrinn
blödliche
Farbeänderung
gibt oder nicht?
Nein, da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Im Urin?
Ja.
Und
ja.
sind
diese Schmerzen
plöstlich aufgetreten
oder...
Nein, langsam. Sie sind langsam aufgetreten.
Nein, langsam.
Haben Sie
Schmerzen
im Rücken
in Ihrem Rücken?
Nein.
Nein?
Nicht im Rücken.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie
irgendetwas,
irgendwelche
andere Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel
Erbrechen
oder
Wir ist etwas übel.
Ich habe etwas Übelkeit,
aber bisher kein Erbrechen.
Keine Erbrechen.
Nein?
Haben Sie Schwindelgefühl
oder Schubanfrost? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe schon seit einer Stunde gemessen.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon seit einigen Stunden Fieber.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Vielleicht seit 5-6 Stunden habe ich Fieber.
Haben Sie Duschball?
Nein.
Durchfall auf keinen Fall.
Ich habe normalerweise regelmäßig Stuhlgang jeden Tag.
Ich hatte zuletzt jetzt
vor
2-Tagen-Stuhlgang.
Das war sehr wenig.
Aber jetzt seit 2 Tagen habe ich kein Stuhlgang mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Wasserlassenprobleme?
Nein.
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Atemnot
oder Auspulver? Nein.
Und Sie
können Sie flachlegen?
Ja, ich kann flachlegen.
Das kann ich.
Okay.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
wenn Sie liegen,
sind Ihre Schmerzen
verliehen.
Ja, etwas besser.
Nicht viel, aber etwas.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brutschmerzen
oder Herzstorpern
oder Herzrasen?
Nein.
Herzstorpern habe ich nicht mehr.
Seitdem ich einen Herzschritt mache,
habe ich kein Herzstorpern mehr.
Okay.
Sind Sie aufgefallen,
dass Sie in der letzter Zeit
Gewicht abnehmen?
Nein.
Ich habe weder zugenommen, noch abgenommen.
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Gewicht gehalten.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist mein Appetit gut,
aber seitdem ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe,
jetzt seit zwei Tagen, ist der Appetit nicht gut.
Haben Sie Schmerzenprobleme
in der letzter Zeit?
Nein.
Aber jetzt mit den Bauchschmerzen habe ich
in der letzten Nacht nicht gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme
mit Durchschlafen oder Einschlafen?
Normalerweise habe ich
keine Probleme, aber in der letzten
Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen,
weil ich Schmerzen hatte.
Okay.
Ich verstehe es.
Haben Sie in der letzter Zeit
irgendwo gereist?
Ich war verreist nach Frankreich.
Ich war eine Woche in Frankreich.
Ich war eine Woche vor
zwei Monaten.
Frankreich.
Und
Sie kontrollieren Sie
regelmäßig
beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, ich gehe normalerweise
regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin,
zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung und so.
Das war eigentlich
bisher immer unauffällig.
Da war nichts.
Haben Sie Probleme
mit Frauenkrankheiten?
Nein.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen allerdings gemerkt,
meine letzte Präzise
war vor drei Wochen.
Und in den letzten Tagen habe ich bemerkt,
dass ich vermehrt Ausfluss habe
aus der Scheide.
Ausfluss?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie
ist Ihr Ausfluss
Welcher Farbe hat?
Das ist so eher hell.
Hell.
Okay.
Ist der ausfluss?
Ja.
Ist es möglich,
ist es möglich,
dass Sie schwanger sind?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Sind Sie schon
vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Meine Hausärztin
schaut immer regelmäßig
in meinen Impfpass und
sagt dann, wenn eine Impfung notwendig ist,
aber bei der letzten Kontrolle war alles gut.
Haben Sie allergien
gegen
irgendetwas?
Nein,
ich habe keine allergien.
Oder Medikamentallergen?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Haben Sie
irgendwelche
Unerträglichkeit
gegen
irgendwelche Ernährung
oder Essen?
Nein, ich vertrage von normalerweise
alles.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein,
ich habe noch nie geraucht in meinem Leben.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Mal bei einer Feier,
vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein
oder ein Glas Sekt, aber das ist selten.
Das ist vielleicht alle 2 Monate.
Schnaps trinken Sie, oder?
Nein.
Für eine
vollständige
Krankengeschichte
muss ich Sie nach
Tragenkonsum fragen.
Das ist eine
Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt
mit
Rogan? Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie
irgendwelche
Vorerkrankungen, chronische
Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, seit meiner
Kindheit habe ich
Zuckerkrank.
Und dann muss ich
Insulin spritzen
je nach Messwert
und Schema.
Ich habe leider mein aktuelles Schema vergessen,
aber das wird nachgereicht.
Das bringt meinen Mann mit.
Ich habe seit 10 Jahren
einen Herzschrittmacher.
Weil ich
habe das nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das heißt
kranke Sinusknoten.
Und seitdem ich den
Schrittmacher hatte,
da geht es mir auch gut.
Ich hatte früher immer sehr viel Schwindel.
Und bin auch einmal
unmächtig geworden, aber seitdem ich den
Schrittmacher habe, ist das gut.
Als Jugendliche
hatte ich häufig Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Und
die Nieren
sind jetzt nicht mehr 100%
nicht mehr 100%ig.
Die Nierenfunktion ist
eingeschränkt.
Da bin ich aber regelmäßig
ja beim Diabetologen
und auch beim Nephrologen in Kontrolle.
Wann
haben Sie letztes Mal kontrollieren?
Beim Nephrologen
war ich das letzte Mal vor 6 Wochen.
Vor 6 Wochen.
Wie war
die Kontrolle?
Die Kontrolle, die Werte,
sagt der Nephrologer, war stabil.
Aber der Nierenwert,
die Nierenfunktion ist etwas
eingeschränkt.
Wie viel
mal
nehmt
wie viel
wenden Sie in Süden an?
Im Schnitt
3-mal am Tag.
4-mal am Tag, manchmal 3-mal.
Aber ich mache das dann
je nach Wert, nach Spritzenschema.
Aber
damit komme ich ganz gut klar.
Und der Diabetologe ist zufrieden.
Im Augenblick ist das stabil eingestellt.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich kann Ihre
Ausausfragen.
Und
Sie
nehmen Sie
regelmäßig
Ausseilinsälen
oder
Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Sind Sie schon
örtliche
oder
operiert?
Als Kind,
da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Und vor einem Jahr
wurde meine Netzhaut
rechts gelaisert.
Weil da habe ich irgendwie
die Netzhautveränderung gehabt
vom Zucker.
Und
dann hatte ich
vor 9 Jahren einen
Kaiserschnitt gebohrt.
Ja, das waren meine Operationen.
Vor 10 Jahren, oder?
Ja, also 2016 war das.
Also vor 9 Jahren
war Kaiserschnitt.
Okay.
Und
Sie haben
Retina Probleme.
Wie heißt
das?
Wie sind Sie?
Retina
Decolmann?
Auf der Netzhaut.
Ich hatte Löcher in der Netzhaut
und das wurde gelaisert.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie
gelaisert?
Vor einem Jahr.
Okay.
Und wie ist der?
Noch.
Mein Vater ist
74 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohen Blutdruck
und hohe Skolesterin.
Da muss er auch Medikamente nehmen.
Ich weiß aber nicht welche.
Und mein Vater hat auch einen
Schrittmacher.
Ja.
Meine Mutter ist auch 74 Jahre alt.
Die hatte
vor 3 Jahren einen Krebs
am Gallengang.
Ein Gallengangskrebs.
Und das wurde operiert.
Und der geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Gott sei Dank.
Ja.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die ist 44 Jahre alt.
Die hat entzündliches Gelenkräumer.
Gelenkräumer.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann
und meiner Tochter zusammen.
Ist Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja.
Welche Berufe haben Sie?
Ich bin Rechtsanwältin.
Haben Sie Stress
bei der Arbeit?
Die Arbeit ist teilweise anstrengend.
Ja.
Das ist so.
Aber ich bin ein
Berufe.
Das ist so.
Aber die Arbeit macht mir Spaß.
Ja.
Frau Halbjörn,
regelmäßig Sport?
Ich versuche 2-mal in der Woche
zu joggen.
Und mache 2-mal in der Woche Yoga.
Und
Frau
Lindemann.
Ich möchte
kurz zusammenfassen
Sie haben seit 2 Tagen
linkseitige
Bauchschmerzen
Nabelstufe
Die Schmerzen
sind dauerhaft
bohrende, wellenformige
Schmerzen.
Und Sie haben auch
Fieber
seit 2 Tagen.
Und
und
ja
diese Schmerzen
verschlittert
bei Bewegung
und Bauchdrücke
bei der Bauchdrücke
und beim Ligen
verlinnt
sich die Schmerzen.
Ja.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder
habe ich etwas vergessen?
Nein, das haben Sie alles richtig gesagt.
Okay.
Ich habe
alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas
an mich fragen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Was kann ich haben?
Ja, ich denke
ich denke
das ist ein
Nierenentzündung.
Nierenentzündung
das kann ein
sein.
Ja,
aber
jetzt kann ich nicht
ganz genau sagen.
Ich
möchte erst mal
Sie
ganz genau untersuchen
und
Blut abnehmen.
Danach
einige
bildgebende Verfahren durchführen.
Danach
kann ich ganz genau sagen.
Okay, so können wir das machen.
Gut, prima.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit
die Patientensprache zu übersetzen
in die Fachbegriffe,
medizinischen Fachbegriffe
und Kolleginnen und Kollegen
haben vielleicht noch Fragen
oder Ergänzungen, dann stellen Sie Sie jetzt bitte.
Ja.
Hatten Sie
für eine Leerwischwerte in die Hand?
Nein, solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
solche Beschwerden.
Ja,
ich könnte nicht genau folgen,
ob Sie
antworten,
wie stark
Schmerzen sind.
Wie stark?
Die Schmerzen
sind jetzt, wie meinen Sie das,
wie stark?
Meinen Sie mit stark
oder sehr stark oder ganz stark?
Auf einer Schmerzkala
von 1 bis 10
Ja.
Wobei ein sehr leichter
und sehr starker
Schmerzmeldung ist.
Also im Anfang waren die Schmerzen
so dann 3 bis 4,
aber jetzt sind Sie bei 5 bis 6,
eher 6.
Haben Sie schon gegen Schmerzen
etwas eingenommen
und nicht meine Medikamente?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht,
ich bin ja sehr vorsichtig wegen meinem Zucker
und wegen meiner Nierenfunktion.
Haben Sie etwas
genommen
gegen Ihre Fieber?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Ich habe erst ja vor einer Stunde
ungefähr oder 2 Stunden Fieber
gemessen zum ersten Mal
und habe das dann nicht geholfen.
Weil ich jetzt Fieber hatte, bin ich jetzt auch
mit den Schmerzen zu Ihnen hier gekommen
in die Klinik, in die Ambulanz.
Ich habe aber nichts eingenommen.
Bemerkens Sie
etwas zum Beispiel
nach dem Essen
fängt Ihre
Schmerzen an
oder?
Kann ich nicht sagen, ich habe allerdings
weil mir auch übel eben ist
ich habe in den letzten
Stunden wenig gegessen.
Ich habe mehr versucht
Tee zu trinken oder Mineralwasser
aber ich habe wenig gegessen.
Könnten Sie genau
beschreiben
wie konsistent
der Stuhl ist?
Der letzte Stuhlgang war ja
jetzt vor
zwei Tagen, knapp zwei Tagen
normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag
Stuhlgang.
Der letzte Stuhlgang war vor zwei Tagen
und der Stuhlgang war sehr gering.
Er war
kein dicker Stuhlgang.
Er war so ein bisschen
wie ein Bleistift
dick oder wie ein Kugelschreiber.
Gibt es andere
Aufregung
zum Beispiel
Blut oder
Schleim? Das habe ich nicht bemerkt
aber wenn Sie nach
Schleim fragen, ja ich habe so in letzter
Zeit bemerkt,
dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
Schleim auf dem Stuhl habe.
Aber kein Blut.
Sie haben
gesagt,
Sie haben keine Rücken-Schmerzen.
Aber
vielleicht
Ihre
diese Schmerzen
sind Gürtelformig sein,
kann man sagen oder?
Nein, die sind eigentlich
mehr nur links im Bauch.
Im linken, mittleren Bauch
auf der linken Seite
aber gürtelförmig sind die nicht
und im Rücken sind sie auch nicht.
Haben Sie oder bemerken Sie
Hautausschlag?
Nein,
ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Die Haut finde ich
ist nicht auffällig,
nicht empfindlich.
Und
bemerken Sie
Ihre
Hautfarbe
oder Augenfarbe
Farbeveränderung? Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen und meinem Mann auch nicht.
Entschuldigung, können Sie Winde ablassen? Ja, etwas, ja.
Und haben Sie Belegungen? Vielleicht. Ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Okay, und ich habe nicht akustisch gehört, deswegen vielleicht noch mal frage ich,
habe Sie Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen? Nein, Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Und riecht Ihr Urin unangenehm? Habe ich nicht bemerkt, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, vielen Dank. So, was sagt der Kollege?
Ja, ich kann versuchen Sie es.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt, Günge Hermes ist mein Name. Ich bin heute bei Ihnen als Assistent als Tätig.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen. Möchte ich Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie für mich eine kurze Zeit?
Ja, habe ich. Ja, es geht um Frau Monika Lindermann.
Sie ist Frau Lindermann, ist 42 Jahre Patiente.
Und das Gebürstotum ist 14.06.1983.
Sie ist 1,74 m groß und wiegt 69 kg.
Die Patiente ist momentan vollorientiert und in gutem Allgemeinszustand und guten Ernährungszustand.
Die Patiente stellte sich bei uns seit zwei Tagen wegen seit zwei Tagen
vor acht Jahren, seit drei Jahren.
Vorhinter, wellen für Kolikartiger, links-seitig, Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, sagen Sie Abdominalschmerzen.
Abdominalschmerzen, ja Abdominalschmerzen, four.
Dschmerzen verschlechtern sich bei Bewegung und bei der Bauchtrücke.
Und beim Liegen verliehen sich die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und die Patienten beschreiben die Schmerzen.
Im linken Seite, in der Nabelschtufe.
Ja, man kann sagen im linken Mittelbauch.
Im linken Mittelbauch.
Die Schmerzen liegt am Anfang bei drei, vier auf einer Schmerzskala.
Aber momentan liegt sechs auf einer Schmerzskala.
Okay.
Hat die Patientin Fieber?
Ja, die Patientin klagt über auch Fieber.
Die Fieber ist 38,5 Mund gemessen.
Ja, sagen Sie es bestehen, febrile Temperaturen von 38,5 oral gemessen.
Oral gemessen, ja, oral gemessen.
Okay.
Die Patientin berichtet auch von Nose, seit zwei Tagen.
Und die Frage nach die Syrienoktöri, Atemnot, Ortopne wurden verneint.
Und auch Tiare.
Ja, die Frage auch nach Schütterfrost und Schütterfrost nachweis,
wurden auch verneint.
Und wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Ja, der letzte Stuhlgang war vor zwei Tagen.
Und die Patientin, als vor Erkrankungen gab die Patientin an,
die Erbettis Melitus Typ 1 seit ihrer Kindheit.
Okay.
Und sie nimmt regelmäßig Insulin ein, dreimal täglich.
Aber sie weiß nicht, wie viel Insulin ist einhalten.
Noch eine Frage zum Stuhlgang.
Gibt es andere Auffälligkeiten beim Stuhlgang?
Also Sie sagen, der letzte Stuhlgang war vor zwei Tagen.
Hat die Patientin immer alle zwei Tage Stuhlgang?
Ja, die Patientin hat Probleme mit Stuhlgang.
Aber ich habe nicht ganz genau gefragt.
Eine Kollegin hat, glaube ich, nachgefragt.
Sie hat berichtet, dass sie in letzter Zeit etwas mehr Schleim im Stuhl bemerkt hat.
Und dass der letzte Stuhlgang in der Stärke etwas dünner war.
Also wie ein Bleistift oder wie ein Kugelschreiberdick.
Das hat die Patientin noch berichtet.
Normalerweise hat die Patientin ja jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Das ist eine Auffälligkeit.
Das muss berichtet werden.
Also wir haben eine Patientin, 42 Jahre alt, die seit zwei Tagen abdominelle Schmerzen hat,
die zunehmend sind, im linken Mittelbauch, ganz überwiegend.
Sie hat keine Dissuri, keine auffällige Mikzonstörungen.
Sie hat febräale Temperaturen, 38,5 oral gemessen.
Sie hat den letzten Stuhlgang vor zwei Tagen gehabt.
Dieser Stuhlgang sei etwas im Volumen etwas dünner als sonst, schlanker.
Und sie hat in letzter Zeit etwas mehr Schleim auf dem Stuhl gehabt.
Was gibt es noch für Auffälligkeiten? Was hat die Patientin sonst noch beobachtet?
Ja, außer Schmerzbedingte Innerpartenz und Schlafstörung ist die vegetative Panamnesse unaufällig.
Die Patientin berichtet eine Reise vor zwei Monaten nach Frankreich.
Wie ich erwähnt habe, hat die Patientin Diabetes mellitus Tip 1 als ihrer Kindheit.
Die Patientin hat auch Pace Maker wegen Krankesinnus-Syndrom.
Sie können auch sagen, Sinusknoten-Syndrom oder Sick Sinus-Syndrom.
Wie lange hat sie den Schrittmacher schon?
Vor zehn Jahren. Die Patientin berichtet auch in ihrer Kindheit,
die wiederholende Pioronephritis haben.
Und die Nierenfunktion wegen wiederholenden Pioronephritis ist ein bisschen probiert.
Es besteht wahrscheinlich eine Niereninsuffizienz.
Deswegen ist die Patientin regelmäßig in nephrologischer Kontrolle.
Vor sechs Wochen hat die Patientin bei der Nephrologie kontrolliert.
Die Miktion ist unaufällig.
Vor zwei Tagen gibt es aufhelligkeiten in der gynokologischen Anamnese.
Die Patientin hat die Schaden-Vaginal-Osclus.
Da gibt es einen Fachbegriff für den Spannende.
Flur.
Wann war die letzte Periode bei der Patientin?
Vor drei Wochen.
Das solltet ihr mit erwähnen.
Es besteht in den letzten Tagen ein vermehrter Flur-Vaginalis.
Mit einem hellen Flur, nicht blutig.
Kann die Patientin schwanger sein?
Die Frage nach Schwanger wurde verneint.
Die Patientin hat eine Schwangerschaft verneint.
Hat die Patientin Operationen hinter sich oder andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Sie haben die Diabetes mellitus Typ 1 mit Schrittmacher.
Sie hatte als Jugendliche pyromonephritiden.
Sie hat eine Niereninsuffizienz.
Sie ist in nephrologischer Kontrolle.
Was sind die Operationen?
Bei der Patientin wurde sie im Alter von zehn Jahren durchgeführt.
Im Alter von zehn Jahren?
Ja, im Alter von zehn Jahren.
Bei der Patientin wurde sie im Alter von zehn Jahren durchgeführt.
Vor einem Jahr wurde eine Lesung der rechtnetzhafte Operation.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Er war 74.
Er lebt noch.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
Die Mutter der Patientin leidet am Colangeo Carcinum.
Wie ist das behandelt worden?
Vor drei Jahren wurde die Patientin operiert.
Wie ist die Schwester?
Die Patientin hat eine Schwester.
Sie leidet am Colangeo Carcinum.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ich lege am nächtlichen Angaben.
Sie haben Ihre Verdachtdiagnose etwas geändert.
Ich lege am Neapolitan.
Sie hat einen Flur.
Sie hat keine Rückenschmerzen.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen gute Erholung.